telle heure à présent de notre module on
va plus loin
[Musique]
et c'est donc l'heure dont on va plus
loin comme chaque soir à 20h40 on
revient ensemble sur deux infos
marquantes de la journée en compagnie ce
soir de nos chroniqueurs Gauthier winsky
de la rédaction de France 24 bonsoir
Gauthier et de la grande reporter à Niva
bonsoir à vous aussi Anne merci de nous
avoir rejoint impossible bien sûr ce
soir de ne pas revenir sur cette journée
historique au Royaume-Uni les
funérailles grandios de la reine
Elizabeth II sont maintenant terminées
elle est en train d'être inhumée dans le
cadre d'une cérémonie privée à la
chapelle mémorial du roi George VI au
sein du château de Windsor elle reposera
donc d'ici quelques instants aux côtés
de son mari le prince Philippe point
final d'une journée vous l'avez vu
rempli de temps fort on va écouter par
exemple un extrait du sermon de
l'archevêque de Canterbury cet état
Westminster Abbey à la mi-journée
dans un discours connu prononcé pour ses
21 ans ça défunte majestée a déclaré que
sa vie entière serait consacrée au
service de la nation et du Commonwealth
rarement une promesse aura été aussi
bien tenue peu de dirigeants reçoivent
le déferlement d'amour que nous avons vu
ce soir on tourne donc la page de cette
séquence très longue un dommage à la
reine Elizabeth II Anne une journée en
tout cas historique on peut le dire
aujourd'hui
oui mais je crois qu'en disant ça on
n'est pas très original parce que tout
le monde l'a dit et je ne sais
d'ailleurs pas quoi dire pour être
vraiment original mais je pense que ce
qui est intéressant c'est que enfin
c'est ça m'est apparu comme ça important
c'est de me dire que dans ce monde qui
est un monde très chaotique en ce moment
où il y a justement énormément
d'incertitudes énormément de de violence
peut-être que
justement les longues journées entre le
décès de la Reine Elizabeth et ses
funérailles et ces moments très
orchestrés très préparés ont aidé toutes
les personnes qui ont été voir qui ont
souhaité aller la voir soit physiquement
sur le terrain soit à la télévision dans
le monde entier à se sentir finalement
un peu mieux
dans ce monde chaotique Gauthier cette
ferveur de la population britannique ça
vous a surpris
bonne question je sais pas à quoi vous
dire oui c'est toujours surprenant c'est
pour ça que cet événement est
intéressant c'est qu'il est il est hors
norme il est hors norme aussi dans son
ampleur par rapport à l'événement réel
c'est-à-dire le décès d'une reine et
d'une reine qui n'a pas été une reine
absolue c'était une reine parlementaire
et donc il y a là effectivement une
quelque chose de disproportionné entre
l'affection qui lui est portée et le
pouvoir qu'elle a eu c'est-à-dire que on
est on a l'impression avec les
monarchies constitutionnelles ou disons
parlementaire que le souverain moins il
en fait moins il en dit parce qu'il est
conquiné finalement à ce statut plus il
est admiré et là on est effectivement
dans l'ordre du fantasme c'est comme
quand on dit par exemple que la reine le
souverain quelle qu'il soit à un
rendez-vous hebdomadaire avec le ou la
première ministre personne donc ça reste
confidentiel et parce que ces
confidentiels on en fait un fantasme en
se disant ils doivent se dire des choses
définitives sur la marge du monde alors
que je veux veut dire qui parle de la
boîte d'allumettes mais enfin rien ne
dit que ça soit des conversations de tri
haut niveau alors à quoi ça sert encore
les monarchies
en deux mots si vous voulez ce qui est
très réjouissant dans cette affaire
c'est qu'au fond on assiste au triomphe
de la démocratie qui a créé la monarchie
parlementaire la démocratie anglaise en
plus à une époque ou sur le continent
européen tout le monde céder dans la
monarchie absolue de droit divin avec
les lettres de cachet etc et là le
Parlement anglais dit non non c'est fini
ça vous restez dans votre boîte et d'une
certaine manière on facilite la chose à
la monarchie parce que on lui dit vous
êtes
muselé par le Parlement je rappelle par
exemple que le père Elisabeth de George
VI était contre l'indépendance de
l'Irlande en 1919 c'est le Parlement qui
lui a dit vous êtes bien gentil mais
vous rentrez au palais et l'Irlande est
devenu indépendante mais au fond on
arrange la monarchie parce qu'on leur
dit vous ne faites rien donc vous ne
risquez pas de vous tromper il y a celui
qui ne fait rien de risque pas de et
donc la monarchie finalement bénéficie
de fait d'une rente de situation alors
que pendant ce temps là c'est évidemment
le pouvoir politique réel le Parlement
qui se coltine qui se frotte à la
réalité
c'est vrai que quand on ne gouverne pas
ce qui était le cas de la reine
d'Angleterre ce qui sera le cas de du
roi Charles 3 et bien on n'est pas
critiqué et donc évidemment du coup la
reine Elizabeth II était bien plus
populaire que par exemple Emmanuel
Macron ça c'est cette dichotomie qui est
intéressante à observer aujourd'hui on
va voir si Charles III sera aussi
populaire que sa mère parce que en tout
cas il a encore du chemin à faire puis
justement pour le moment c'est son fils
aîné qui est plus populaire que lui dans
les sondages donc on verra si la
couronne se fit tout le temps au chiffre
on verra ce que ça va donner son fils
est plus populaire il y a des aspects de
sa personnalité à Charles III ou en tout
cas des actions qu'il a pu mener
auparavant qui peuvent rassembler disons
autour de sa personne et susciter une
autorité un peu égal à celle de sa mère
avant d'être roi Charles était le prince
de Galles que nous avons tous connu et
dont toutes les frasques étaient
analysées critiqués médiatisé il a quand
même un excellenthropique en faveur
aussi de aujourd'hui
et donc le l'exposition médiatique à son
égard sera complètement différente et
bien sûr que ce que vous venez de dire
c'est-à-dire
ces thématiques de l'environnement etc
sont des thématiques qui va essayer de
de prôner mais moi je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il règne très longtemps
Gauthier pour rebondir un peu sur ce
qu'on dit est-ce que il y a une remise
en cause de la monarchie peut-être aussi
à prévoir dans les 14 autres pays sur
lesquels techniquement Charles III règne
alors ça c'est intéressant parce que
vous savez que par exemple en Australie
il y a d'ores et déjà un ministère de la
République c'est-à-dire quelqu'un qui
est chargé à minuit
finalement peut-être le changement oui
tout à fait la première ministre
néo-zélandaise a formulé le souhait très
clairement que le pays sorte
républicaine
la Jamaïque aussi si je ne me trompe la
Barbade qui est déjà forte avancée dans
le dans le domaine qui est devenu
d'ailleurs je pense déjà une république
bon donc
vous avez aussi le comment dirais la
volonté de trancher par rapport à une
histoire qui concerne l'immigration
aussi en ce qui concerne l'esclavage
notamment pour les pays des Caraïbes
mais ce que je relève dans ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure vous disiez vous
demandiez à Anne si le nouveau roi
Charles III était capable de maintenir
l'unité ou de fédérer mais bon son
bonsoir le privilège d'une démocratie
c'est aussi de s'énerver parfois c'est
d'être dans la contradiction on
progresse au nom de quoi Charles
devrait-il fédérer les Britanniques
alors qu'on a bien vu que sur le brexit
ils étaient
au fond le pays ne sait pas disloqué
mais c'est intéressant d'avoir des
frictions comme ça et j'allais dire que
l'aspect consensuel du royauté
finalement si elle arrivait jusqu'au
bout de ce projet serait extrêmement
ennuyeux pour la démocratie ça
conduirait à une forme d'empathie et on
sait où vont les démocraties quand elles
sont à mortes vous évoquiez le brexit et
maintenant cette séquence mémorielle
passée ça va être un leurre du retour à
la réalité pour les Britanniques avec
notamment ses factures d'énergie qui
vont sans doute encore beaucoup augmenté
et puis plus généralement un pays dans
une très mauvaise situation économique
oui effectivement on va voir d'ailleurs
justement si les cheminots les postiers
dont les syndicats en Grande-Bretagne
avaient déjà commencé des grèves avant
le décès de leur souveraine vont les
reprendre ils les avaient cessé par
respect pour la reine donc même même ces
syndicalistes avaient décrété qu'ils
allaient cesser de faire la grève
parfait pour le décès de leur souveraine
mais il y a beaucoup de problèmes
l'inflation est à deux chiffres il y a
une dette publique galopante en
Grande-Bretagne donc il y a énormément
de travail pour la nouvelle Première
ministre qui peut-être aujourd'hui a
profité du fait que énormément de chefs
d'État étaient là pour leur parler en
marge de ces funérailles on n'en sait
rien parce que comme c'était des images
de la BBC on a pratiquement rien vu
c'est-à-dire on a rien vu tout était
centré sur la reine d'Angleterre ce sont
ces funérailles mais peut-être pas assez
en tout cas au vu de certains sur
justement quelles étaient les leaders
politiques qui a parlé avec qui dans les
couloirs etc on a littéralement rien vu
mais c'est certain que on a ils en ont
les uns les autres et sans doute la
première ministre profiter pour se
parler pour essayer de commencer à
résoudre les problèmes alors autre thème
on va plus loin ce soir encore une fois
l'Ukraine avec ses nouvelles inquiétudes
autour d'une centrale nucléaire cette
fois celle de PIF des no cryings qu'au
nord de décès et de mikolaïve cible
d'une frappe russe
et j'ajoute aussi qu'il y a quelque
chose qui que j'ai trouvé très
intéressant mais ça c'était quelques
temps auparavant lorsque madame
zellenska a été interviewée par nos
confrères de France 5 et elle a dit une
chose que je trouve profondément
judicieux elle a dit vous savez cette
guerre n'est pas une guerre pour des
raisons géopolitiques celui ou celle qui
croit qu'il y a des raisons
géopolitiques à cette guerre et
pardonnez-moi a-t-elle dit déjà victime
de la de la propagande de Poutine la
raison de cette guerre ce n'est pas les
inventions de sécurité sécuritaire de
petit la raison de cette guerre c'est le
jovinisme grand Russien qui est à
l'oeuvre et c'est j'ai trouvé ça très
judicieux parce que ça remettait les
choses en place donc finalement pour
répondre à votre question je trouve
qu'elle avait tout à fait sa place à
Londres aujourd'hui
maintenant revenir sur cette frappe près
de la centrale au nord d'Odessa il y a
de quoi être aussi inquiet que pour la
centrale des aporida c'est ce qu'on sait
dans le mot sur ce qu'on vient de dire
je pense qu'il aurait été mal venu et
mal admis justement par le peuple crayon
que ce soit veulent la diverses qui
lui-même qui viennent qui quittent le
pays pour venir assister à ce
funérailles donc ça semble tout à fait
acceptable et normal que ça soit son
épouse quant à cette centrale à pif
diennot ou crainsk effectivement on se
retrouve dans la même situation que
celle de zapoorija puisque elle devient
le théâtre le lieu de bombardement mais
on ne peut pas
empêcher si vous laissez pas nous ni
personne finalement qui décide où se
passent les bombardements sauf les
belligérants qui sont en place c'est à
dire si les bombardements sont cette
centrale viennent de Russie ce qui a
l'air d'être le cas c'est la faute des
Russes et puis si ce sont les Ukrainiens
c'est la faute des Ukrainiens donc quand
vous êtes dans un pays en guerre tout le
pays potentiellement malheureusement
la cible de bombardements domicile du
coup là aussi il faut des experts de la
UEA sur place en permanence pour juger
simplement il y a deux éléments ce que
disait les experts de la ioa qui ont
visité la polygnes c'était que le risque
majeur n'était pas forcément un
bombardement à moins qu'il soit ultra
ciblé et avec des missiles extrêmement
puissants que le risque majeur c'était
qu'on manque d'eau pour le
refroidissement des réacteurs et que si
par exemple des installations civiles
qui approvisionnent l'eau était touchés
le risque était beaucoup plus grand pour
les centrales nucléaires et d'un mot
quand vous voyez par exemple que l'un
l'une des apprentis Goebbels du régime
de Kremlin margaditte Simonian qui
dirige le château des Spoutnik etc dit
maintenant parce qu'elle est pousse au
crime elle dit il faut viser les
installations civiles il faut viser les
écoles il faut viser les centrales il
faut viser l'électricité
là on est peut-être dans le cas de
figure que signalé Anne et c'est là que
ça devient très dangereux on a aussi
beaucoup parlé ces derniers jours de ses
centaines de corps exhumés à is you mais
l'enquête est en cours pour déterminer
les circonstances exactes de la mort de
ces personnes mais l'écrasante majorité
de ses corps présente des signes de mort
violentes on a quand même un espoir que
les responsables soient jugés un jour
ce qui concerne justement l'IEA qui a
été asporisa il me semble également que
malgré ce déplacement malgré leur
rapport
est-ce que ce qu'ils ont dit a été
entendu
donc il faut quoi Gauthier encore plus
d'aide militaire pour que cette
contre-offensive ukrainienne qui est en
cours soit beaucoup plus rapidement
décisive vous savez ce qu'on dit
d'habitude comme ça sur les plateaux de
télévision on dit oh ce conflit il n'a
pas de solution militaire c'est presque
une phrase toute faite la je suis désolé
dans l'état actuel des choses je ne vois
pas compte tenu de ce qu'on peut appeler
négociation mais négocier avec Poutine
nom d'un chien je ne vois pas comment on
peut arriver à quelque chose en dehors
de la solution militaire pour ce que
disait je suis tout à fait d'accord
effectivement l'essentiel c'est de
prévenir la chose maintenant vous vous
souvenez que quand on a parlé de ce qui
s'était passé en Yougoslavie de
milocheville etc on a dit non ça sera
jamais possible en Afrique et ça a été
fait quand même donc il faut avoir cet
espoir mais c'est vrai que la priorité
c'est ce que dit c'est-à-dire faire en
sorte que ça ne soit pas à toutes les
villes libérées par les Ukrainiens qu'il
n'y ait pas ce type de d'horreur absolue
c'est déjà la fin on va plus merci
Gauthier merci Anne pour vos éclairages
quand vous restez avec nous prochain
point complet sur l'actualité dans
quelques minutes